was it always theater for you though or
did you are you really into TV as well
oh I was a latchkey kid
so we will meet I watched you know far
too much TV
me too but look at us now yeah I used to
watch like it's it's it was so bad or
good however you looked at it like I TV
sitcoms and stuff are still a huge
comfort to me like is it like when I go
to sleep and stuff I can laugh yeah I
could just put on like an episode of
cheers and like the theme song like puts
me I know all the theme song do you
really don't you remember like I mean I
feel like there was a time when every
show it was like the theme song was huge
yes making your way in the world today I
didn't know okay you know my favorite
was what was the one where they had the
guy Arkel they had what was it Family
Matters my woman that song and then that
that one lady that went like wow like
that was my favorite one cuz she was
just like wailing and I was like I want
to be her I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this